there's nothing she
[Music]
they're gone gross new playthrough
excitement yay horror games I love
wouldn't feel let's play horror games
and skip scared agony everybody a game
where you go through hell we play the
demo I'm sure nothing will be wrong with
getting this game monetized at all let's
begin
what the hell too many questions just
let me play thank you it's extremely
loud this game nevermind it's supposed
to be pretty intense so please guys
police washes with a parental guardian
it's the last thing I remember
I wonder what I did to enter hell part
my soul consumed by the endlessly
burning fire
sounds like Brad is doing the voice
acting
[Music]
streaming
he turns again into ashes
the overlaying tissue revealing ruined
phones are not running around to the
blackest place where light scores per
yak darkness this is a strange
rollercoaster into a place which
deprives one of faith and erases
memories
which leads to madness and to faces the
boundary between people and animals
[Music]
jacksepticeye someone told everybody
red goddess
her shine shrouds are the memories
she is the key to the gate of unending
agony
she is the answer what an intrepid body
loads that I must follow he keeps going
the red goddess here we go when we get
to start the game it runs smoothly I
don't know why anyone cares I guess we
came from the butt hole and now we have
to like go through all of his intestines
and stuff that's pretty good
well this place is Jo look at this damn
honestly not sure if I would mind going
to hell this looks pretty cool at least
Lee you know I can appreciate the
aesthetic of this place I could be ie
that's this is a pretty neat-looking
place I am eating drag with objects okay
I can do that
got it oh geez when was the last time I
had a shower
yucky ducky duck barri I just realized I
can probably turn off
[Music]
Toby eye-tracking I don't have it here
damn it I know you I can turn off some
of the more graphic stuff I just listen
I don't care this is the rules of
YouTube well I guess not okay
jeez at least it was worth a shot
alright damn look at the look at the
bones incredible how many people must
have died here probably a lot of people
I'm a genius
alright look at that I don't know why I
did that but I just did it
make it more cozy in here lettuce
scented candle you know you know I'm
gonna go ahead and say it so far hell
has not been that bad I don't get the
discrimination of how everyone say oh
you'll go to hell not that bad press f
to cast an astral link and show the next
goal but use it wisely it has limited
resources I didn't even want to click it
you tell me it's a limited resource and
I just wasted it you think I can't
figure out okay I need to go we're just
kidding this way got it I got it
what am i torch go all right I burned it
forgot about that this is going good
it's going pretty well make an offering
at the altar this is the altar this look
like um Bioshock something's missing
here
alright what's in this one nothing you
gotta find Jackson nutsack hey that was
a joke I'm sorry game yeah this isn't
Ripper phobia types shiz okay I like how
I'm playing this game and ah I'm alive
it's just very hard to see I probably
lit up the gameplay for you guys but I
see nothing but blackness okay so back
save yes wait oh this is awful now I
like it okay now I can see where
actually where I'm going oh I fell down
there it was impossible to tell oh I ran
out of stamina oh yeah there you go oh
that sound terrible alright guys so does
everyone that goes to hell have to like
prove themself with puzzles it's like
I'm not worthy if anything I should just
stay here right oh not enough not enough
hearts for you huh okay fine I did saw
one what a little swim
a note I don't want to know must be
another way down there
ow ow that really hurts what's up what
is this oh hey how you doing
high five now fine that's fine all right
let's check down here Oh what was that
nothing
fantastic well you've been most useful
whoa oh of course I forgot I had this
thing all right well I don't know how to
tell you but I can't go through there so
Oh perhaps I need to jerk him harder you
know come on I'm charging oh my god dude
like he had legs how bad I thought it
was just without everything okay well I
guess we're going down here instead
maybe not abandoned prison everybody
okay that's fine
it reminds me a bit of Dark Souls you
know you start off as is disgusting
peasant which is not much different from
me waking up every day
I'm sure she's fine
I take that back
I take that back I'm sorry yeah oh Jesus
my own shadow scared me
I'm a little spooked down how about that
yeah yeah key duckie are you doing that
you're right you're right carrying that
you're right you need that you need a
hand
you need a hammer they appreciate it
buddy appreciate it hey there's too hard
they're excellent flew into my hand
let's just yeah all right why not why
why the heck not you can set things on
fire price okay it's dangerous lesser
creatures bigger demons will be
attracted so remain cautious okay I feel
pretty good
not gonna lie you know it's all about
attitude so you're in hell huh what are
you gonna do cry about it it's not gonna
help anyone that's totally fine
I suppose I'm supposed to burn this i
just right-clicked and it took me out of
the game yeah heck yeah guys we're so
smart on this channel figuring out
puzzles left and right see hell is easy
I don't why people complain so much can
you burn already geez I don't have all
day
Wow now I'm on fire what happened here
alright let's um hmm okay alright shadow
people that's all I got from them sorry
I'm not a big fan of reading in video
games not my thing takes me out of it
too much I bet this is his pubic hair
the 2012 PewDiePie sex jokes is back
everybody how about that let's squeeze
through here that's right yeah nice and
tight I like that are you doing oh you
look good man you look good me see you
later buddy nice is there a very oh oh
look at this the gates of hell how about
that oh I escaped I escaped everybody
how are you top of them on and this is
fantastic this is just is it raining
what is it raining off yeah
yucky ducky that's a mouse hey can you
stop all right this is getting it's
getting a little gross
okay I'm burning down this for reasons
unknown I just like to see things burn
you know surprising lack of firing help
I will say I will say that I know bit
controversial oh wow there she there you
are
she looks different bye all right yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh god what is that
whoa that's creepy I'm not sure where
I'm headed
I like how the game doesn't yeah why I
did not ask for that that is super gross
begone T word
hey ate what that where'd it go oh geez
ha ha ha got him all right where did I
come from what is this oh it's some
guidance unlock content in the main menu
yes yes my favorite thing okay we can
squeeze through here we're back in the
prison how's it going here guys how we
all doing in this place
so now we can burn down let's follow
this make it easy for herself hey we got
to talk to you how you doing buddy hey
do you like in here as well hammer
rotting here because of you what did I
do
I don't remember you I should have
killed you when I had the first chance
man you seem real upset crying isn't as
bad as burning I suppose bring me the
torch okey-dokey well whatever you say
big boy all right these are torch places
I gotta say him join this game so far
it's pretty cool here you go buddy
Sun Oven what the Hat excuse me the
language can we
what you called my mom Oh BA G word I
mean if we word sorry I get him good
news well that was fun that was pretty
cool I really enjoy that okay now we can
go here all right dude you had an exit
what an idiot
what an O look we're here where I
thought it saw in the beginning I am
like the smartest in old time over
universe my god I don't get enough for
rewards in life
hey that's not what I meant to do Shh be
quiet
oh god I'll be going now I'll be going
now thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you Jesus
[Music]
okay I go this way thank you oh I don't
like this Jesus sorry I just thought of
a random memory had nothing to do with
what just happened I don't get scared by
video games like a child I wasn't that
bad see we made it no problem at all
fantastic look at this display system
there is no fire I will accept this but
forbidden fruit for many it's a sinful
item but for you it's something special
you can use it in the skills menu to
operate a skill only the forbidden fruit
name is you to upgrade your su thank you
have an ample okay yeah that's
definitely definitely how you eat apples
okay so skills reduces level of sound
increases the time the player can hold
their breath give the player the ability
to survive weak attacks
I will go with sound because when I play
the demo that was like my main issues
they just spotted me so easily wow
that's a cool maze all right we got the
fruit what do I do now I'm not just
gonna jump like some crazy crazy
sometimes you need to take a step
forward what the freak game that was
awesome
smash eloquent right now
ah
geesh who's laughing I'm not laughing
that was hey it's an upside-down hard
find this sigil to unleash the ritual
okay I think I remember this you have to
like draw it or something
yeah hey look it's a peener
and I didn't want to draw that all right
so we need to find it somewhere
how you doing buddy oh did you see unite
okay yeah we have to any sudden movement
as if they saw everything
I saw once i saw one of them give up the
chase more meat because if i had was
more alluring maybe he just wanted to
warm itself there is something in fire
that attracts these beasts I wouldn't be
come to a dance to that Joe that's the
cool game mechanic to attach to fire
we would have better chance you
okie-dokie hey what's one of these oh
god they scare me
alright so be careful about that part
sheesh jeez guys you need to get up here
or to have to find this sigil this could
be it I'm pricing to look at it but it
didn't but I ble oh is that that's a
sigil isn't it it's a V right there has
to be it
alright let's just try and draw a B
through this okay
please guys don't make fun of me my
painting skills that's all right yeah
yeah except hooray yeah so smart so
smart
thank you guys you need at least a
couple like you to play this game I did
not press that
okey-dokey you came with me skull take
it
it's Scully everyone remember him from
amnesia
I know
[Music]
No
[Music]
Demon's rely on different says is study
your enemy environment to use it in to
manage press old to hold your breath
Frank thank you guys for watching part
one of agony if you want more let me
know and leave a comment and all the
likes that you leave it will really help
support that thank you guys so much for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one stay awesome
[Music]
[Music]
you